Hello everyone and welcome to another broadcast of HoloTalk.
I'm here today with Oz Yetkin, who is president and CEO of Yetkin Telesystems.
And Oz is going coast to coast here in the United States, and he's researching three-dimensional imaging systems, and he's here in the studio with us today.
How are you today, Oz?
I'm great, Frank.
Thank you very much.
If I could just have you hold the microphone up close.
There we go.
I thought it would be interesting for you to come on the show to let listeners know something about some of the competing technologies that holography is facing with three-dimensional imaging.
And I know you've gone around the country and you've seen some of these startling uh three-dimensional effects that's being created by other systems.
What are some of those systems like and uh how does holography compare to them?
Sure, let me summarize.
I actually have been working with these 3D technologies for a while.
I worked on them with uh NASA for a while, and it's always been interest of mine.
The easiest system that people can approach right now are L C D shutter glasses.
These are glasses, these are electronic glasses that work either with a uh monitor, a CRT monitor that's capable of high refresh rates, or with what some of the newer projectors that can support refresh rates of about a hundred hertz or a hundred and twenty hertz.
The basic principle is that the monitor displays left and right eye images in succession.
It's called frame sequential uh stereo.
Um and the glasses alternately block out the right and left eye, thus giving the user the illusion of 3D inside the monitor.
Uh the problem, the main problem with these is one, you need a graphics card capable of driving them.
And two, if your refresh rate is not high enough, it gives you a headache.
You can see the flicker from fluorescent lights.
However, most 3D technologies right now are based on this or something similar to it.
Uh and you know, I'm looking to resell some of these technologies, so I shouldn't bash them too much.
But e Dimensional is a company that makes the cheaper version of these glasses.
Uh crystallize on the other, I mean that's about a hundred, two hundred dollars per pair.
On the other side of the spectrum is crystallized, which you know, places like NASA use which have the better quality.
This is, you know, starting at the low end, that at the higher end you have similar systems.
You have dual projector stereographic vision systems.
Places like IMAX and some other movie theaters use this.
This is where you take two projectors, either film or electronic, you stack them together with polarizing filters on each of them, and shoot the images at a non-depolarizing screen.
So it has to be a special kind of a screen, um like a silver screen that's not necessarily cheap.
Um but a lot of movie theaters might be equipped with them.
Um you wear what are called passive polarized uh glasses, where each um each side of the glasses blocks a part of the image.
Thus you get an illusion of stereo.
The advantage to that is you get very nice, excuse me.
You get very nice depth, you get very nice stereo.
You might get some ghosting if it's not set up properly.
And they're kind of expensive.
That's a the ghosting would be, I guess, a registration issue, right?
Well, it can be a registration issue, but more importantly, it's an issue of a polarizer not being perfect.
I see.
And you know, there are different types of polarizers.
There is uh linear polarization and circular polarization, which I won't go into simply because my physics is not enough to explain it.
Um but these are the this is what you have to do if you have a large movie theater.
Otherwise you can get to a very, very, very expensive um stereo projector that can do, say, 120 or 144 Hertz um and have the electronic glasses to go with that.
I know there is a company called Real D that's doing something like that that's has really high power projectors.
Uh there's something called the Z-screen that goes in front of the projector, uh turning that frame sequential uh stereo to something that can be viewed with regular passive polarized glasses.
So these are the technologies in that realm.
There's also something else.
I'm actually reselling this.
Um it's the Arasawa P240 uh monitor.
Um this is on a more personal scale rather than a theater scale.
That's correct.
So this takes the same idea um and actually does away with the need to have a very high refresh rate.
What this technology uses is you know, L C D panels are already polarized.
I mean L C D uh the L C D technology uses polarization to block off the right type of light to make the picture.
So this monitor polarizes the picture uh pixels alternately.
So for example, E1 pixels might be the image for the left eye.
Odd pixels might be the image for the right eye.
Oh, that's interesting.
And very, very simple too.
It's I mean it's very simple in concept.
I'm sure it's not easy to get that registration.
So these monitors, and there are a couple other companies making them, I believe.
This is the only one I'm familiar with, the Arasawa monitor.
Um they only require passive polarized glasses.
The advantage is you know, you get really good depth, you get a very clear image, and you don't have flicker.
Disadvantages um you still need a certain viewing angle.
You still need to be in about 15 to 20 degrees of the image.
But that's actually a good solution, you know, ranging from two to four thousand dollars as far as I know.
Um you still get a very I mean it's a personal system.
It's the price point has gone down from the professional to the personal.
I see.
But the larger systems used by places like NASA go from thirty thousand up.
So this is a more much more of a personal uh thing that you could have in your uh home.
I have two in my office.
They're wonderful.
I can watch three D movies with them.
They work really well with uh uh 3D interleaved uh DVDs of which so you you don't have to have program material that's been specifically encoded to be placed on this screen.
Well, you do actually, but there is software out there that takes regular DVDs and uh tries to convert them into three Dr.
I see, it could it's like a conversion process.
And the converted DVDs are not ever as good as a movie actually.
Something that would be shot, yeah.
But they it actually does well.
What is uh easier to do is to take a 3D image source, for example, to take a game and actually intercept the graphics rendering pipe uh pipeline and extract those two images.
And there are drivers to do that.
So you can take a game like World of Warcraft, download a download a five dollar driver, and actually use it with this monitor.
Okay.
And you know, play the game in 3D.
Or you could have, if you have, for example, a stereo microscopy application, you know, those dissectic microscopes that surgeons use.
Um, you can put cameras on the microscope and have a live feed.
And I know um several surgical uh teams and several medical schools have used this technology to train surgeons.
You know, because when you see, for example, the brain surgery being performed in 3D, it looks a lot, it looks like it's got a lot more information.
Because I know a brain surgeon than 2D.
But I can I uh you know, having a biology background, I can actually see that depth.
I can actually see that value in 3D.
Uh so that's the polarized kind of displays, whether you know active shutter glasses or passive polarized.
And they run the gamut from large theatrical productions all the way down to something that would be personal just for an individual.
That's correct.
As far as your scope.
Now there is another type of technology.
These are the auto stereoscopic monitors, and I think these are the displays that actually try to compete with holography.
Okay.
So these are um usually, not always, but usually based on lenticular uh screen technology.
This is when the monitor or the monitor, it could also be a print, has uh microprisms in front of it, with each prism directing a strip of the image.
You have to interleave the image properly for this.
Uh each prism directs a strip of the image to a different viewing zone.
So within about twenty or thirty degrees, you have eight or nine different images you're viewing.
Kind of like what you do with a stereogram.
Okay.
Um the advantage is you don't need glasses to see it.
And you can print these pretty cheaply.
You can actually print these, get a sheet for uh maybe like two dollars from microlens or a similar supplier, register it on your sheet, and um you know, it has some depth.
You've probably seen these I've seen them in commercial applications, I think already with a few fast food places on their large menu uh displays and things.
Am I correct about that?
You're absolutely correct about that.
You probably have seen them on gift cards, serial boxes.
There was a company called Nishika in the eighties and up to the early nineties.
Oh, with the camera.
Yeah, they had a camera and it was wonderful.
It was a very high uh lines per inch kind of uh um print that they made for you from the images you sent.
Unfortunately, that company of yours got out of business.
But I'm actually going to go down uh to North Carolina to talk to microlens about this technology in my survey of three D technologies.
Um so this is easier to work with.
The monitors are approaching affordable.
I three or four years ago I uh looked at the syntagram monitor, which was based on this technology.
It was pretty good.
It did not have as much depth as I would have liked it to have for the application we needed at the time.
So it did not have as much depth or clarity as the shutter glasses.
However, something like that is wonderful for a marketing kind of application where you can put it in the display window, and you know, people going by see it.
The disadvantage, and the biggest disadvantage for this is you sacrifice resolution for depth.
So if you have nine different viewing zones, that cuts the resolution of each viewing zone in in nine.
So with those monitors, for example, the syntagogram was built on a three two hundred to twenty four hundred uh L C D monitor, if I recall properly.
But when you were displaying a three D image, you couldn't really read text on it.
You didn't have to resolution.
Uh and the viewing zones are limited.
So once you get off of the viewing zone, you get into the new viewing zone, there is a shift.
Now there are advances made being made in this field with eye tracking or stereoscopic monitors.
The advantage is you no longer have the viewing zones.
The monitor follows changes itself to follow where the viewer is.
This is that the disadvantage is that you have um only one person who's able to view this thing at the time at one time and make sense out of it.
I see.
Now there's another kind of technology that Ogma sees I should mention.
It's head tracking technology.
As y your listeners know holograms have parallax.
And they should know that and if they don't I'd be very disappointed in them.
Maybe they should be looking to different shoulders.
But um holograms have very good parallax both vertical and horizontal and uh that's why they can be viewed by multiple people at the same time.
Most of these technologies do not have parallax.
Most of these technologies um have only one image.
The lenticular screens and lenticular prints have some parallax you know say as much as a stereogram that you might make about eight nine images.
I haven't seen them with more than that.
But to compensate for that there are systems that uh require the user to wear a head tracker.
This is a fixed degree of freedom tracker that tracks the user's location in space and how their head is oriented.
And the computer is instructed to change the uh scene so I mean if you have that information if you're driving this from a 3D application um so that you get the illusion of looking at something like a hologram.
For example, there is a system called the Cave, which is three to six walls of stereo uh that the user is immersed in.
When you're inside that and you put on those L C D shutter glasses with a tracker attached to them, you're basically in something resembling the holodeck.
It's very convincing.
You can you know using a three-dimensional mouse you can grab objects, you can walk around objects, you can look under objects.
Um so this is a way to augment these systems to make them more convincing but where would someone go to experience something like this the cave.
You know I know NASA has several uh several uh universities have them um a more affordable system is the Immersidask which is a one wall version of this I see.
Um unfortunately I don't know if there are any commercially available systems for this actually there are two more technologies I forgot to mention.
I'm sorry I'm jumping from place to place here.
Uh there are head mounted displays which I'm sure everybody's heard of I mean when people think virtual reality they think of the helmet.
Yeah.
So these helmets usually work with the head tracking.
What they have are two different monitors embedded inside the helmet that you put on and there is head tracking so you are essentially immersed inside the world uh in inside this virtual world these are becoming more affordable.
I know there are uh helmets under a thousand dollars right now I have yet to there are eyeglasses which are quite popular.
Um the problem with the cheaper HMDs is the limited field of view.
It's not quite like being inside the world.
It's more like being inside the world looking at looking through revolving goggles.
When you get the stereo, you get the stereo vision, you get the head tracking, and you can move around.
But it's they're kind of heavy and I have not seen any HMDs right now that are very good that you know I would might spend three, four hours in.
If you if somebody does want to experience this, however, there are various uh really high-end video arcades that feature these.
One I can think of off the top of my head is DisneyQuest at the near the Epcot Center.
Not inside Disney World itself.
But near downtown Disney in Orlando, they have a place called DisneyQuest which is about a five to six story gate video arcade.
And there are some systems there featuring HMDs which are actually very entertaining.
There's the magic carpet I mean this was a couple of years ago there was one game that was immersive where you had something like a sword and you were battling cartoon characters.
Okay.
That's the most immersive game I've ever played.
So there is this technology and you know I'm hoping the price will come down because really wonderful applications would be enabled with high quality head mounted displays.
I think they're working on something with cycling for training.
They have something now that runs off of a PC and you look at a monitor and you can buy rides like the Tour de France and whatever.
But they're working on a helmet so that you can be immersed into the environment that you're cycling in and the trainer that you're working on that you attach the bike to is controlled by the computer as well.
So if you start to go up a hill there's more resistance applied to the bicycle on the trainer and you actually feel like you're going up a hill resistance wise anyway.
Heart rate goes up, breathing rate goes up.
That would be a great application for something like that.
And and there are several sports training.
I did not know about that.
That that's that sounds very neat.
Uh there are several applications like this.
Um one of them was I saw at a conference was from the University of Hawaii.
They had a virtual beach.
Now I don't know why anybody would need a virtual beach in Hawaii, but they they were trying to treat post traumatic stress syndrome, you know, with full immersion.
Um now I'm for one I'm rooting for this kind of technology because I'd love to have a helmet, you know I could plug in and you know program virtual worlds in.
I don't think we're there yet in the civilian world.
I think there are really higher end HMDs like twenty thousand dollars and up that have the field of view required for full immersion.
Uh but for actual immersion, for the most holodic like experience, the best thing I've seen is uh the cave and its related technologies.
That's stereo, L C D shell glass stereo with head tracking.
Now I did see one amazing display at Sidgraph last year.
It's uh a very popular graphics conference where everybody comes and showcases their technologies and yeah presents their papers.
I might have seen that.
There was one hologram based there was a company called Rabbit Hall that had very that had a very convincing three D hologram.
I think they're on the more expensive side but you probably know more about those than I do.
Uh what I saw was a display called the Holographica well it's made by a company called Holographica from Hungary.
And this is a very large display using a holographic optical element as a screen.
I see.
I don't know much more about its technology except that it supports sixty four viewing zones, requiring at this time sixty four projectors.
But the what the image you see is amazing.
I mean the image you see is basically without glasses, this three D animated thing floating in space.
And you know, I hope these companies don't get mad at me.
Everybody loves those uh floating in space uh images, right?
Yeah, and this is what people expect, but uh they almost they almost had I mean you're still looking at a screen obviously, yeah.
And I think their price was about a three hundred and fifty thousand dollars.
Okay.
Now none of these displays, to the best of my knowledge, have things like focus information.
They don't capture the phase information that's coming from uh that a hologram captures.
Are you th speaking and referring about depth of field?
Well you say and the ability to focus on different parts of the image.
Oh, I see.
Now there may be work going on in this field that I'm not aware of where people are working on uh this kind of information, but there are things in real life in 3D that you take for granted.
For example, if you were to hold your finger in front of your eyes and look at it, you see that your uh eyes converge on it and everything else becomes double vision.
Yes.
You f look further away, your finger Yes.
You see two fingers.
I mean, this is a part of the visual cues that you get in the real world.
This is what you're used to, even though it's not immediately apparent that you lack it when you're look watching an IMAX movie.
But this ultimately causes eye strain.
So a hologram capturing every single thing that's coming from the object, perhaps except the color, doesn't have this.
So it's got that clarity that you can't necessarily have in these uh other systems.
Obviously, holograms are really not competing with these systems since you don't have um full commotion holograms yet.
Um by the way, there is another exotic kind of technology, and your listeners might be familiar with this called uh volumetric displays.
This is one you're where you're spinning uh a screen very fast and projecting images on it so that inside that space, you know, you have three D.
But uh the one I saw was done with a D L P projector running at two hundred forty Hertz.
Oh, I see.
But I I'm sure they've been down with L C D arrays, I'm I think they've been done with lasers.
Okay.
You know, they look convincing, but it's mostly with uh line art or whatever or I it is.
I've seen video with the D L P version I saw at Sid Graph, there was actual black and white video of a man running.
Oh, I see, okay.
Which was amazing.
Which was like a full motion hologram in space, except of course you can't reach into it.
But I think that technology and uh the hardware to support it is a little little ways off yet.
Do you ever do any searches on the web to find holographic displays and then see that what you're looking at really isn't a hologram that it's some other type of display and it's just being called a hologram?
Are you finding that a lot?
I I'm finding that quite a bit.
Everything that's 3D it calls itself holographic.
I mean, from the illusion, uh for example, the other stereoscopic display I got was called a synthogram.
I mean that's a intentional allusion to a hologram.
To um there are these displays that have literally smoke and mirrors.
I mean they have some sort of mist projected into space.
They they project an image and they say holographic image.
Uh it is said he appeared as a hologram in Tokyo.
What they used was uh uh gauze kind of uh fabric with his image projected onto it.
I mean so far from holography that it's not even funny that to even call it a hologram.
And I I I sold the company, I don't remember its name now.
I there's been arguments on the web that that was a hologram.
And it's like uh I uh it's enough to drive people insane, especially if you're a holographer.
I'm sure it drives you insane.
You know uh I've seen let's see.
Uh I've seen the case system referred to as holographic which you know I can kind of buy I mean it's not holographic obviously but uh you know you had the same kind of parallax so it's similar holography.
I s the L C D shutter glasses I got um were topping themselves as a holographic three D experience from your PC.
I see.
Which is not the only system I saw that I thought was doing this which is not is the holographica system which does use a holographic element in it.
Okay.
Um but yeah I that must be annoying to you.
That must be and and and those in the holographic holog holography community.
Yeah well it's getting worse.
That's uh it's it's very difficult because it's more difficult because of uh uh public expectations of what a hologram should be when they come to see a hologram.
And it's not floating around the room and it's not being projected somewhere and it's beautiful three dimensional images on a wall but that doesn't seem to count anymore.
Now talk to George Lucas I think Princess Leah ruined it for you.
She's the culprit, right?
Yeah I mean that holographic projection from R2D to I think that's what people expect.
Yeah.
That's wh I think that's what started a lot of I mean there there had been some films where holograms have been in the films before that.
Um but I think Star Wars was what uh what probably started that notion of what a hologram should be as far as something being projected out in space.
Now who knows, maybe someday we will get a technology that is capable of projecting images out in space.
Um I've heard of things proposed with intersecting high power lasers in air and heating up the air so that's plasma box all there.
Yeah.
I don't know if those will ever happen, but they still won't be holograms.
Well the thing is l you know, light doesn't stop anywhere, you know, it continues to move.
It's you can't send it out twelve feet and tell it to stop and form something.
But I I've heard of what you're s referring to as far as um uh ionizing the air, you know, where the two lasers intersect.
But then you've got lasers that continue on after that intersection point, so I'm not quite sure what that would be.
Yeah.
So what are you what's your future plans?
You you're working with holography here in the lab and uh you've seen holograms.
What's your uh I you've done holography in high school.
That's that's right.
That's right, right.
Early on.
So I I have to thank Mr.
Van, my physics teacher from Walatosa West for giving me the opportunity and getting me s you know started on this.
Um my plans are I've started Yetkin Telesystems, which is a three D products and services company.
I want to offer all sorts of um 3D products ranging from these relatively expensive, you know, I'd say they're cheap of course since they're not thirty thousand dollars, like these four thousand dollar projectors to you know, three dollar view master style f uh cardboard viewers.
Mm-hmm.
And I'm going to offer all of these technologies, hopefully holography as well, to my clients uh in Turkey.
Uh I'm I'm sorry, the company over there, or in the United States is the case may be, who are interested in not only just buying these things but also integrating them with whatever they're doing.
So for example, might offer 3D movie theaters for hotels for higher end hotels using these projector technologies.
I might go to an arcade and you know, set them up with the 3D monitors or set them up with a real projected, you know, a three D system where you know with some head tracking where their users feel like they're inside the game.
You know, take a m basically creating miniature versions of these K's and immersed discs that you know are in the you know sub ten thousand dollar range.
Um I'm hoping with the holograms to sell them to companies.
Um Frank has this wonderful way of doing uh logos uh with a relatively simple process from a uh computer image that float in space.
I think that has that has potential as a really cool novelty until it saturates the market and I've never seen them, so you know it's the market is pretty empty of those.
Um I would love to offer and be able to do holograms, you know, custom holograms for companies with their logos and such.
Um they're good for trade shows, conventions, you know, when they have a booth or something.
The one that I have over here on the wall was actually used in Dusseldorf, Germany for a book fair, you know, a book convention, a worldwide book convention.
And it's basically for a draw, you know, you you want to get people to your booth.
You want to get people to get your company's information.
So they uh actually the holograms I did for them were thirty by forty centimeter, that's an eight by ten there.
But they put those in their booths, and they had people, you know, standing around looking at this logo floating out in space, and their salespeople could go out and you know, approach them to give them information about the company.
At this point in time in two thousand seven, I think anything 3D still draws crowds at trade shows.
For example, at Siggraph, you know, the rabbit hole company that had a f full color or you know seemingly full color hologram, had people congregated around it asking the owner what this was.
I mean they couldn't even figure out it was a hologram.
So, you know, for anybody trying to differentiate their product, I think, or differentiate themselves at a place like a trade show or even a shop, it's a great conversation piece.
It's a great uh crowd draw.
I mean you say on your webpage vanity is like the ultimate marketing tool.
Well, it is in a sense, you know.
But I mean I'd love to have that with myself, that's why I say that.
Yeah.
But you know, uh I I'm basically going to spend the gamut of three D products and services and hopefully, you know, bring it to a place where it really hasn't been that popular in in the past.
I want to thank you for being on the show.
I'm sure the listeners found what you have to say about 3D competing technologies very interesting.
I think they may be already aware of some of them, but you may have had you know a few in there that uh they hadn't heard of before, and some of the ones that they did hear of, you probably clarified a few things for them.
But out of all the technologies, including holography, I would have to ask you this before we close the show.
Which one gives you the best visual three-dimensional space?
Well, I think holography is untouched in terms of clarity right now.
You know, if you want to see something that's as real as the object, I mean holography is a holy grail, and I think you know, these people who are working on those technologies, myself included, understand this.
That's why everybody is saying, you know, the our technology has holographic clarity.
It's a holographic experience.
Mm-hmm.
You know, the whole you know, holograms don't substitute for things like interactive three D, which most of these technologies are geared towards.
But if you had to archive like museum materials, I think holography is the way to go.
That's interesting because there's a conference coming up in London next year on archiving museum materials.
From the hologram you could probably go to all these other technologies.
Yes.
Well I want to thank you for being on the show, taking uh taking your time.
And the two of us are now going to go over to the holography table and we're going to do some work.
And uh thank you for listening to the show and hope you tune in for each new installment as they become available here at uh HoloTalk.
So thank you and good night.